it was november 3rd 1991 and blake
newsome loved his job
he had a passion for organization an
undying love of american political
history
and was a lifelong member of the
republican party that's why he took
great pride in his position as a filing
clerk at the ronald reagan presidential
library
or at least he did until his horrifying
encounter with
scp-1981 the worst day of blake's life
began like any other
he was taking inventory of the archives
wide array of betamax tapes
and making sure that they were all
arranged carefully and conformed with
the filing system
one by one he checked footage of
speeches and addresses off of his list
until he came upon a strange tape that
had no business being there
the tape looked to be completely normal
but it hadn't been recorded on the
archive inventory
and there was something else off about
it a single white sticker was on the
front of the tape with ronald reagan cut
up while talking scrawled hastily with
what was probably a felt-tip marker
blake was shocked and appalled they
hadn't even spelled the president's name
correctly
what poor mr newsome didn't know was
that he was about to see something so
disturbing
that he'd look back on that misspelling
like it was a treasured childhood memory
standard policy for tapes like this
would be to review and catalog
or even throw it out if necessary
typically a lowly filing clerk like
blake would need to seek approval from
his superiors
but curiosity got the better of him he
commandeered one of the library's
televisions and betamax cassette players
and started watching the footage for the
first minute or so nothing seemed out of
the ordinary
just the president standing at the
podium giving his iconic evil empire
speech to the national association of
evangelicals at sheraton twin towers
hotel
orlando florida on march 8 1983.
however the second the tape hit the one
minute and 10 seconds mark
something unnatural began to occur
president reagan's speech began to veer
off
as the topic of conversation shifted
from the importance of family values
to the exquisite taste of human flesh
blake was taken aback
but surely he was hearing things but the
tape only got worse
president reagan began to divulge the
fact that he enjoyed the taste of young
flesh the best
particularly that of infants as reagan
began to go into detail about how
exactly one should best cook an
infant if you want to seal in the flavor
the crowd erupted into modest applause
blake started to feel sick he'd
remembered watching this speech
and president reagan had said nothing of
the sort
things only got weirder as the
president's cheeks suddenly opened up
into a long bleeding gash
as though someone had cut into his face
with an invisible knife
as the speech continued and reagan's
words became more nonsensical and
incoherent
the injuries got worse too his face
developed puncture wounds like he was
being stabbed
skin in some areas rotted and peeled off
reagan showed no awareness of the
horrifying injuries that seemed to be
occurring spontaneously on his body
this was a living nightmare the tape
came to a merciful end
22 minutes in after president reagan's
throat appeared to be slashed open
and his insane speech was reduced to
quiet gurgles
it fizzled out into static shortly after
and blake politely retired to the
bathroom to throw up
was this some sick prank or tampering or
camera trickery perhaps
he didn't know but the tape was
disgusting
and whoever was responsible had to be
punished
newsome contacted the police hoping
obscenity charges could be pressed
against the creator of the tape once
they were found
the tape was taken into evidence and a
low-level police investigation into the
possible culprits began
while the police officers who viewed the
tape reported nightmares in the weeks
following
the creator of the tape was never found
the investigation truly came to an end
when a superior closed the case
and the tape disappeared from the
evidence locker this
as you probably could have guessed was
the work of a field agent from the scp
foundation annistics were then used to
erase the memories of everyone
unlucky enough to witness the tape
including blake newsom
who could finally rest easy and return
to his filing work
the anomalous tape was now in
responsible hands
it was given the designation scp-1981
and given the object class safe
due to its easily controlled and
self-contained nature
proper research and testing was now able
to begin and while nothing about the
construction of the tape suggested
anything inherently anomalous repeat
viewings of the video made it clear that
this went far beyond mere doctored
footage of a presidential speech
every single time the tape is played
both the speech made and the injuries
received by president reagan change
the few rules the tapes seem to always
follow are that reagan never reacts to
the injuries he's receiving
it always has the same beginning and
total run time and the speech is always
corrupted
the speeches have been described as
mostly incoherent lacking any sort of
underlying thematic structure
and largely being composed of
nonsensical anecdotes and parables
so not that dissimilar from a regular
reagan speech but the topics always turn
incredibly dark and have included
torture mutilation
death cannibalism ritual sacrifice
genocide and more the range of injuries
shown on president reagan in the videos
have included
but are by no means limited to
impalement mutilation
and some tortures so gruesome that the
details have been redacted from official
files
on several occasions the details of
president reagan's speech have also
eerily predicted the future
these include successfully predicting
the september 11th attacks in 2001
and the outcome of the 2008 russian
presidential election
incidentally this isn't even the only
reagan-related scp to predict the future
no there's another entity in this
incredibly specific niche
scp-095 a highly degraded copy of a
comic known as the atomic adventures of
ronnie raygun
the title character bears a striking
resemblance to president reagan
despite the fact that the comment is
confirmed by foundation test to have
been written
in the early 1930s the comic is set in
the far-off future world of the 1980s
and follows a number of ronnie's
exploits in three stories
the first titled ronnie vs space admiral
carter seems to perfectly describe the
events of the 1980 presidential election
the second space assassin mirrors the
attempted assassination of president
reagan by john hinckley jr
and the third titled jungle planet
retells the iran contract controversies
of 1986.
these comics were produced under the
mysterious and apparently non-existing
company future funnies
the foundation hopes to track down the
other comics from this company whenever
possible
but they've had no luck on that front
for now there's only
scp-095 during initial testing
foundation staff watched the tape
frequently in case this strange
corrupted version of president reagan
had any other valuable predictions for
the future
however during one of these screenings
one of the d-class observation personnel
pointed and yelled at the screen in
horror
upon further examination of recorded
footage researchers could see exactly
what had concerned the d-class observer
so much
while in other viewings of the tape
president reagan's press detail had
appeared totally normal
in this one something was clearly a miss
standing among the other dull
suit-wearing political aides was a tall
figure dressed in a midnight black cloak
with a large conical hood
obscuring his face the figure didn't
appear to move in the footage
it just stood there menacingly a later
survey indicated that this figure would
appear in roughly one in seven veilings
of the tape
this cloak figure was designated
scp-1981-1
and he became part of the recurring
imagery in the nightmares that often
followed a viewing of scp-1981
naturally despite containment and
preservation attempts the foundation was
aware that just like any normal tape
natural magnetic interference would
eventually degrade it beyond use
attempts to copy the footage onto
another betamax tape failed to reproduce
the anomalous effects
that's why the foundation has
painstakingly recorded any video and
audio they could
via a standard commercial camcorder in
one particularly terrifying playback
scp-1981-1 took the president's place at
the podium
staring directly into the camera the
words i see you
appeared over a black screen shortly
after staff members were ordered never
to make an attempt at communicating with
the figure
and instead contact a level 4 superior
if such an event occurs during a
playback again
the frightening and unfortunate effects
of scp-1981 would come to their logical
conclusion
under the watchful eye of dr james kyle
robinson
managing archivist of inert safe class
objects and anomalous items at site-73
he was contacted by special agent arnold
rodriguez and special agent ethan tate
members of the secret service with a
duty to protect president reagan
word had gotten to reagan that there was
an anomalous artifact in the possession
of the foundation that directly
pertained to him
and he wanted to see it dr robinson
obtained files and transcripts
pertaining to scp-1981 and handed them
over to the agents
but refused to allow president reagan to
see the tape directly without approval
from o5 command
but reagan and the agents were
persistent eventually o5 command ordered
a private screening of the tape for
president reagan
at the sanford chemical processing plant
a front business owned and operated by
the foundation for amnestic production
dr robinson offered president reagan the
use of amnestics after the session
completed
but reagan declined the screening took
place in conference room b
and the tape was replayed three times it
was on the third playback
that things took an interesting turn as
the mutilated reagan on the screen began
to rant about drinking the blood of a
child from the skull of vladimir putin
reagan began to silently mouth along the
words as though he remembered them
he spoke about beings known as the
destroyers and potential apocalyptic
events to come
after the screening reagan once again
refused the offer of amnestics and
departed
it seemed as though all was well until a
violent break-in at the sanford chemical
processing plant that left a night guard
dead a large number of amnesics had been
stolen during the break-in and security
footage showed that agent tate and
rodriguez had been responsible
the two agents were tracked down and
traced to the residents of ronald reagan
where the foundation came upon a
disturbing site the agents had pillaged
large quantities of class
a and b amnestics and supplied them to
president reagan
who at some point after observing
scp-1981
had been driven into a dangerous madness
the two agents wanted to cure him before
he caused harm to himself or others
but their bungling had come with severe
consequences
misapplying such a high quantity of
amnesics had essentially destroyed
reagan's mind
and while the foundation was able to
stabilize his condition his impaired
memory and cognitive function would
leave him unable to care for himself
independently in order to cover up for
this grievous mistake
a cover story was concocted about reagan
falling victim to alzheimer's
and facing severe cognitive decline as a
result
both agents tade and rodriguez were
fired for their actions
had their memories wiped by the
foundation and were assigned new
identities
dr robinson for his part in the disaster
had to face a foundation ethics
committee disciplinary hearing
while scp-1981 continues to be
classified as safe due to its
unlikeliness to ever breach containment
when you consider the havoc it rot on
the mind of its singular target
safe is hardly the word that comes to
mind it's enough to make you wonder what
other tapes are lurking out there
just waiting to be found
you